it's The Showdown of the century Ahsoka
vs Dory from Finding Nemo put away those
lightsabers though because today's
battle is all about the whales in the
fifth episode of Ahsoka the titular Jedi
experiences a roller coaster ride that's
wild even by her considerable standards
after losing her door with Balin skull
she finds herself in the world Between
Worlds where the Force ghost of Anakin
Skywalker guides her through her
unresolved issues and past regrets this
being Anakin the trading involves a fair
bit of tough love
trying to die when Ahsoka makes peace
with her past and chooses to live things
somehow get even weirder having finally
figured out a way to follow Morgan
ellsbeth's faction to a Galaxy that's
far away from the galaxy far far away
Ahsoka communicates with hyperspace
hopping per girls space whales somehow
she manages to hitch a ride inside of
perguel's mouth before the Pod makes a
jump to light speed the Star Wars fans
who know their Pixar films the scene
that shows Ahsoka talking with the
massive space whale might seem familiar
in Finding Nemo the running joke of Dory
supposedly knowing how to speak whale
pays off in magnificent fashion when
she's able to communicate with a blue
whale which swallows her and Marlin and
transports them to their destination
[Music]
wow I wish I could speak well both
scenes are extremely impressive and
let's face it weirdly similar but which
film did it better Finding Nemo was
always going to get a head start on this
if only because the Pixar film was the
first to do it well not the whole
swallowed by a whale thing of course
that's an old Trope that appears and
works ranging from Pinocchio to the
Bible still when it comes to the exact
beats covered by Ahsoka and Finding Nemo
Dory comes ahead of Ahsoka by two
decades no less apart from the time
advantage to Finding Nemo version of the
scene also has another significant Pro
in its Corner the loving patient way in
which it sets up the whale moment Dory
starts the movie as a Cloud Cuckoo
lunder it seems to be far more annoying
than she is used for maybe I should try
humpback no don't try humpback
whoa it actually sounds sick over the
course of the movie Her positive
character trade slowly unfold as she
turns out to be a great friend with a
whole host of hidden deaths the whale
scene captures a journey perfectly after
the movie has painstakingly set up Dory
is supposed the ability to speak whale
as fake at best and fraudulent at worst
the audience and Marlins suddenly
discovered that she was telling the
truth all along from this point on Dory
is presented in an entirely positive
light and plays an instrumental part in
Nemo's rescue there are plenty of
poignant scenes in Finding Nemo but the
whale moment to find story is a truly
memorable character and may very well
have played a part in the fact that the
movie sequel revolves entirely around
her in the Ahsoka Corner the perguel
scene doesn't exactly come out of the
blue the creatures have already debuted
in live action in the Mandalorian season
3 and previously played a role in
earlier Ahsoka episode it's a known fact
that they can travel in hyperspace and
Ezra is demonstrated in Star Wars Rebels
that certain Force sensitive people can
communicate with them since they're also
the only creatures left in the Galaxy
who might have an idea of where Ezra
might be it makes sense that Ahsoka
would need their help because of this
the perguel seen in ahsoka's fifth
episode gives off a distinctly different
vibe from Finding Nemo's whale scene
where the latter is hectic shocking and
completely in line with the mildly Panic
tone of the rest of the movie Ahsoka
space whale moment is deliberate and
Majestic with side notes of
inevitability all in all it's quite
befitting for a heroic effort to stop
thrawn from returning and reforming the
empire in terms of drama and Shia Stakes
then Ahsoka wins a whale battle with
Flying Flags however as far as moving
poignant scenes go it's hard to top
dory's crowning moment in Finding Nemo
then again maybe we shouldn't be putting
these movies against each other in the
first place after all shouldn't we just
be glad to see a popular franchise
character climbing into the mouth of a
giant whale every couple of decades man
what a world
[Music]
oh